I cannot believe Nancy then it has been
40 years since the first hard to believe
as an edge yeah but the original not
only star Jamie Lee Curtis but a future
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills and
with the new Halloween coming out next
month well only eg got Jamie and Kyle
Richards gather again
Laurie Strode oh lordy years later
babe that sounds crazy new at forty
years later I know I always have that
memory of me on the last day of shooting
with you carrying me all the way back to
my dressing room yeah I never forgot
that so I have all I have a lot of great
knowledge about beautiful memories of
you beautiful might be a bit of a
stretch where these two shared the big
screen in 1978 Jamie was babysitting a
nine-year-old Kyle in the iconic slasher
movie do you think that movie like
Halloween ruined the babysitting
business cuz it you know making the
movie I was never scared seeing myself
in it was terrifying
well there is a sequence that involves a
babysitter and it's just terrifying the
2018 version of Halloween picks up 40
years after the original film Michael
and his mask are back where a final
showdown with Jamie she's sort of this
untreated trauma victim for 40 years I
have prayed every night that he would
escape so I can kill him I'll have
people come up oh my daughter she just
loves you in Halloween and the child
ideally I snap them like this I'm like
what are you telling me she's fine she
loves them
[Music]